[Musique]
voulez-vous bouteilles d'eau bouillante
poulet
j'écoute les tamas parce
qu'on est des connaissances
on a eu nos cinquante volontaires qui
ont coûté chacun 4 vinaigre balsamique
pour le faire on
va le faire goûter aujourd'hui trois
bières servier jamais les trois ça c'est
si le job
en fait goûter des créateurs de la sauce
barbecue du reste du chocolat ratoma
vivis qui fédérera le pain aux raisins
les olives noires l'art les chinois
glaçage la glace à la dégustation
j'adore
pensons seulement
c'est un hommage à
ayant chacun une particularité
[Musique]
j'ai commencé par
de nature je mettrai une aide qu'aux
vieux pote et moi jamais
non ce choix de dire j'ai fait
[Musique]
quand j'étais jeune je faisais des sacs
du quart
[Musique]
bobine
est ce que c'est bon oui oui
j'aime utiliser line j'adore le bon
joe cole est en fait c'est bon - le
groupe cherche une entière
[Musique]
je parle d'une
dégustation de trouver de fumer c'est
moins bon que ce que j'ai goûté chez
nous moi je
sais la texture qui me dérange
c'est
qu'on ne sait pas le produit seul comme
un goût de l'étude
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez déjà mangé saartjie
chami je savais pas que ça existait le
caravage et ce avec quoi des craintes en
jeu suite au secteur
j'autorise vous coûter 1 au barde et les
kids and away j'avais une sensation il
est
vrai père noël vacances
les probables échappées et doivent
atteindre ce stade pas je connaissais
pas comme chapeau texan dîner si je me
souviens pas de la pole et non parce que
c'était dur mais j'ai des gens fassent
un deuxième temps à
volonté
merci à nos buts en une mi-temps et un
prochain test de mots pour expliquer sa
lancée dans ma préférée c'est sale et
partage